e
e e
[Music]
Christian
good evening and
welcome my name is cat and my pronouns
are she and her and we are so glad that
you're
here uh this evening have a couple of
announcements one thing is every two
years uh
lgbtq Christians and allies gather from
all over the country and they meet here
in Dallas to attend the three-day
centerpiece
conference this year's uh conference is
October 24th through the 26th if you are
looking to connect with other
like-minded Christians or just want some
resources to help you think through the
Theology of being open and affirming
then this event is for you scan the QR
code to find out more
information knock your mama's Sunday
School classes back it will be this fall
meetup group will run October
27th through November
24th it's an hour and a half per week
class where we we will read through the
gospel of
Mark it's the perfect space if you are
deconstructing wrestling with how you
view scripture or simply want to learn
more about the
Bible and I'm going to give a little
plug for this Meetup Group because my
wife Suzanne this is the Meetup that we
attend Megan does a very good job
facilitating we have some wonderful
conversation
uh anything any questions are fine and
and be open-minded and it it really
helps you see scriptures differently and
historically and it if you're interested
come come check us out we'd love to have
you so that's also October 24th through
the
26th no that's 27th through the 24th
sorry um now uh these candles are a sign
I thought one of them went out okay
these candles are a sign of the presence
of Christ Among
Us fully
Divine and fully
human please stand as you're able and
willing as we begin our
worship now we exit the kingdom of noise
hurry and
productivity now we enter the kingdom of
silence and
Stillness and
Grace now we enter Sacred
Space a space for
prayer worship and
adoration a space to encounter
Christ revelation of God heartbeat of
creation
my love finds
you find
us may we all come
[Music]
home thank you Cat um we're gonna get
started with our worship set and before
we do I quickly just wanted to put names
on faces for any of you who don't
already know the people in front of you
this is Gary and he's actually on our
leadership team here at the table and
this is Caitlyn Caitlyn wears Min hats
at the table uh she works with slides
and she works with our admin and she
works with our worship team and my name
is Mindy and this is Caleb and Caleb is
also a Community member and this week I
was just thinking about the gift that it
is to I mean there's a a lot of churches
who do worship differently and this is
no um shade on any of them but a lot of
churches have a group that's paid that
comes up week after week plays their
songs finishes goes out the door and
there's never any interaction between
the people in the community and the band
that's on the stage but these are our
community members these are people who
are taking time not cuz they're getting
paid or getting anything back but people
who are just giving their time because
they love this community and they want
them to experience Jesus so I just
wanted to say thank you to this group
that's up here and there's others out in
the audience Maggie and Jesse are here
um who aren't on stage and Nate is
usually here with us I think he's
touring tonight but like this isn't
their day job it's not even their night
job some of them do music and get paid
for in other places and still choose to
come here so I just wanted to say thank
you um to this team of people that I'm
so blessed to do music with Eden's done
music with us in the past and and I'm
now seeing other people but anyways just
as you see them out amongst amongst the
peoples um if y'all could just love on
them um cuz I just really really am
grateful for the time they pour into
this team um and we're going to talk
tonight throughout our songs there's
kind of this theme of remembering that
we aren't just um machines we're not
just these uh workers that go to our 9
to5 and clock in and clock out and we're
not just here because it's a Sunday
night and this is what we do on Sunday
nights um sometimes it's easy to forget
that and it's just we're going along
with our routine but we actually get to
choose to show up here and engage with
the spirit of God and with each other
and his spirit in each one of us um so
let's remember that tonight this is a
gift this time is a gift this community
is a gift and let's engage it and
receive what God has for us all
right one
2 we dream of
you on City
street breathing again in our
bones we dream of
you at kitchen
s Your Glory filling our
homes we are
not beasts of
Burden we are
children of
GRA and the
blue in our
col is the
Garment of
[Music]
Praise we dream of
you
uncont strolling along with our
[Music]
friending
heart let
[Music]
to be together
again we are not we are
not Beast of
bir we are
children of
GRA and
Theon in our
col is a the
Garment of
P we are
not Beast of
bur we are
children
of and
the in our
colors is a gar
[Music]
of let the Earth
Rejoice let the Seas
ReSound let the people sing the songs of
Joy let the rocks cry
out let the riv
let the people sing the songs of
Joy let the Earth
rejo let the SE
out oh let the people sing their song of
Joy let the rocks cry out C out and let
the rivers
rooll let the people sing their songs
we are
not be of
bir we are
children of
GRA and the
blue in our
colors is a
garment of
let the
Earth and let
the let the people sing the songs of
joy and that the rocks cry out C out and
let the rivers
[Music]
roll let the people sing their song
all right you kids are dismissed to go
to your
classrooms thank you guys for helping
them back in the back Katie and
Maggie Angie was back there doing
checkin I think Kelly's back there
tonight
and we're going to transition into the
prayers of the people so if you guys
would follow along on the screens with
us and read the parts that are in red
and then feel free to offer out loud
anything that you're carrying into this
space tonight we want to hold those
before God
together Jesus for this city of saxi
Texas and for every city and community
and all who live in them we pray to you
for the Good Earth you have given us and
the wisdom and the will to conserve it
we pray pray to you for the old and the
sick for the Widow and orphan for the
injured and suffering we pray to you for
the poor and the oppressed the
unemployed and destitute for prisoners
and captives and all who remember and
care for them we pray to you for the
vulnerable the marginalized and those
unjustly targeted for their gender
sexuality race or other perceived
difference we pray pray to you for those
experiencing loss loneliness and
disconnection and for those struggling
with mental and emotional health we pray
to you Lord we know that you love us and
that you hear us so we lift these names
and situations up to
you Alex and
Lucas for those affected by the
hurricanes
for the
Duncan
me Lord for the names and the moments
that we have spoken aloud and for those
that we have kept in our hearts we pray
to you that they may have life and light
healing and hope peace and a deep sense
of your presence
amen God we bring you the work of our
hands and now lay it down lay it at your
feet what we've done what we build what
are we
broken lay it down lay it at your
feet you
hold it
all Jesus you hold
[Music]
worried Hearts weed H weaken
bodies lay it down lay it at your
feet will we used well we've lost what
we've
wasted lay it down lay it your
feet you
hold it
Jesus you
all you
hold Jesus you
hold it all
[Music]
all our dreams all our f are
ambition lay it down lay it at your
[Music]
feet and even if nothing comes to
fruition lay it down lay it at your
Fe you hold hold it
all Jesus you
hold it
all you
all Jesus you
hold it
[Music]
all all our dreams all our P are in
lay it down lay it in your
feet if nothing comes to
fruition lay it down lay it your
[Music]
feet lay it down lay it
my the Lord of my
heart not be el el to me say that
thou now my best thought
by day or by
Night
waking or
sleeping thy
presence my
love be th my
WIS and th my
true I ever with the and thou with me
Lord thou my great
father and I th true
son thou in me
dwelling and I in
[Music]
the whiches I
empty
braise now my
inheritance now
[Applause]
[Music]
and now and now
only be
first High King Of Heaven
my
treasure
now you
are
[Applause]
forious
silver Lord you
are more
cly
than Lord you
are more
beautiful than diamond
nothing
I Compares with
[Music]
you of
Heaven my
[Music]
victory may I reach heaven joys
Bright
Heaven Heart of My
Own Heart
whatever
fall still be
my oh
[Music]
R be my vision oh
ruler of
all still be my
vision oh
ruler of
all so God I pray that you would be our
vision that you would go before us that
you would light our paths and be a lamp
unto our
feet that you would give give us
Clarity where we have
confusion that you would bring Comfort
where there is pain and
hurt where there's been damage God would
you repair
relationships would you heal our
hearts and would we be your hands and
feet that offer Love and
Hope and for
forgiveness when the rest of the world
is screaming
hate and
bias and
division would we be
peacemakers thank you for being our
example our
model our source and our
beginning keep bringing us back home to
you in Jesus name name
amen you guys can go ahead and turn to
the people around you and say hello
[Music]
well Grace and peace my name is Brett
pronounce he him and uh it's so good
it's so good to be with you all to
welcome you into this space and uh as
always that includes those joining us
online love youall lots and don't forget
to grab your communion stuff for later
in the service and uh anyone here
tonight who is new thank you for being
Among Us I know how much courage it can
take to come through those double doors
it can just be a lot especially
depending on past Church experiences and
how all that's gone and uh so yeah so
we're just really really grateful that
you're here so um we are beginning a new
series tonight titled Jesus and politics
and uh if you're nervous nervous about
partisan political rants from me uh
don't be um you know one of our values
here actually the first one is
thoughtful and uh I've really done my
best to kind of think through this
series in a as thoughtful way as
possible and uh I really honestly
debated about doing it or there's
different ways to do it you know and uh
that's actually why we did so many
one-off sermons like an unusual amount
of one-off sermons preceding this
because I just kept pushing this back a
week I was like maybe it's my INR 5
you know mode I was just like I think
this through more I need I need more
time you know so I just kept one off one
off one off and uh and I think I even we
kind of consider doing a you know like I
think the whole vibe of course in the
country right now it's very anxious so I
was even talking with my my good friend
Jesse Watts uh about like maybe we
should just do you know kind of a a
whole call me anxiety in the midst of
Elections you know I mean kind of that
whole approach and I sat down to write
it and I just couldn't I I think I felt
like I was avoiding you know what I mean
and I was like ah dang it okay just
classic BR here we go another uh light
and breey message at the table I just I
can't do it I just like y'all are like
can you just chill out sometime and just
go easy like no got no chill
unfortunately so um anyway I I am I'm
looking forward to it though I mean I I
hope it is in the end um helpful
insightful and uh maybe gets us thinking
um just in some in some fresh fresh ways
so you know of course as I named though
this is a time of high anxiety I mean if
you're like on you know Tik Tok if
you're on the YouTubes or cable news for
those still watching the old cable news
I mean it's it's hard to avoid it you
know I mean it's just the every twist
and churn every misstep and missp and
you know just everything now is sound
bites you know what I mean so it's just
looking for that hook looking for that
uh juicy you know thing and I think it
just it kind of adds to this whole vibe
of uh just anxious an anxious country
and uh and of course you know a lot
that's for good reason Joe I'm not even
saying it's just you know sort of
frivolous or silly like there are real
implications to policies and how things
play out and you know for sure uh so you
know I think we could maybe though at
times Wonder like well if Jesus were
here like in his kind of physical
material body we understand he's here
like through the spirit but in his
actual like tangible physical body uh
like how how how would he relate you
know to the political situation to
politicians and who would likely want
his endorsement you know like how how
would all that play out you know and and
kind of from that how what does that
maybe mean for us you know and uh so
that's that's kind of where we're going
is to look back and to ask like well of
course we don't have him in his physical
body like here and now with some very
overt example but we can do is go back
and kind ask the question okay well how
did Jesus relate to kind of the powers
that be how how did he relate to
politicians and and the political system
as a whole and and start to at least get
some hints I'm not claiming in this
series to have kind of like the final
word you know after you after you hear
this series you'll really know it all
you know um I think it'll be more of
hopefully you you understand maybe the
questions at the very least understand
the questions we should be asking and
wrestling with um because I think even
just doing that becoming a more
thoughtful people uh and I'm thinking
here not just at the table but even the
broader Christian Community uh would go
a
long way real long so if we can do that
I think I'll I'll take that um that as a
win
so before we jump in though I also want
to mention that um I am drawing from
other thinkers and writers of course as
always I I like to mention this um
partly because I think at times pastors
and preachers and folks can sort of
deliver a thing as though it's just sort
of like straight from the mouth of God
you know and sort of getting around the
fact that they are
interpreting and so I like to name who
I'm drawing from because I am
interpreting the scriptures I'm
interpreting Jesus you know and I'm
having voices other voices and people
I'm reading and thinking through to kind
of help me do that so I want to always
like kind of have those cards on the
table and if you want to you know extra
credit you're like like I'm going to
read these books you you knock yourself
I'd be so happy uh so there's two books
in particular the first is I judge no
one a political life of Jesus by David
Lloyd
dusenberry and the second is Reckoning
with power why the church fails when
it's on the wrong side of Power by David
David Fitch and both of those are
excellent and insightful I'd say the
first one's a little more academic um
and second one's a little more readable
but uh still they are both written by
academics though so um I think they're
both trying to though kind of write in a
way that's like you know for not just
their colleagues so it's I found it you
know pretty readable um so okay that
little caveat in mind the title of my
message this week is a strange figure a
strange figure and David dusenberry in
his book I judge no one he he kind of
closes out chapter one with this uh this
statement he says I believe that if the
figure of Jesus is to be thoughtworthy
in the future we must break with the
modern tendency to reduce him to his
miluse like in other words is sort of
his context you know in the city of his
youth Nazareth in the tetrarchy to which
he legally belonged Galilee in the Roman
province he visited Judea and in the
holy city where he died Jerusalem I will
argue um or sorry Jesus remained in ni's
words a strange figure it is this
strangeness that shaped his political
life and that led I will argue to his
death as a political criminal it is this
strangeness too that makes Jesus life
intriguing and his sayings still worthy
of
reflection so why that's kind of the the
question driving this message um here at
the beginning is
why was he a strange figure a strange
figure for his own time uh and as I'll
contend uh for our day and age so uh
this is kind of in ways a key theme
throughout the gospels uh Matthew Mark
Luke John that no one can quite figure
out what Jesus is up to like what does
he want exactly
and and this is why there's kind of
widespread confusion I mean some a lot
of this I would say was actually
people's
expectations uh which perhaps we bring
you know as well to Jesus we kind of
expect him to be
someone and then he's like not and it's
it's perplexing it's it's kind of
mystifying so to to kind of begin to
understand uh what Jesus was about and
how might all this relate to politics
what I want to do is um lay a little
groundwork so the first thing to know is
that uh about 60 years before Jesus uh
birth the Romans conquered Judea and the
surrounding area Jerusalem city of
Jerusalem the whole area so this is kind
of the
political context in a way is that Jesus
and his communities like they're they're
conquered by a foreign um
Empire and so this this kind of brings
up question okay so how did people
relate you know like what were the
groups like today we kind of have like
the Republicans and the Democrats sort
of this two- party system with a few
offshoots but they're like pretty small
you know um so what were like the groups
and the factions and the you know what
was going on in Jesus day so there were
um there were really like four main ones
uh the first would be the Sadducees if
you've read the gospels you might
recognize that term uh so they were like
the uh the Priestly Elites they ran the
temple they were very cozy with the
Romans uh buddy buddy you know these are
like uh your I don't know your Princeton
grads or something you know it's like
they were they had money they had
influence they had power they were
um kind of in control there so you know
okay so was Jesus you know this kind of
landowning Priestly kind of person uh no
not by a long shot in fact we know from
the gospels he criticizes them uh quite
harshly so yeah so he's not a sadducee
so okay next group was he a Pharisee so
the Pharisees were um basically kind of
middle class folks like the Sadducees
are sort of upper class Pharisees were
more middle class and they cared for the
common people they wanted to provide a
kind of religious way of life for
them and like in in many ways uh Jesus
may have been closest to the Pharisees
in terms of his own alignment we know he
himself was you know an artisan a
carpenter kind of a working person you
know likely kind of in that middle class
and we know right he's uh friend of tax
collectors and Sinners and such so knew
you know sort of common people cared
about their religious way of life and
such so in that sense he's kind of you
could see him a bit of a Pharisee
however if you've read those gospels you
also know he reserved his absolute
harshest criticisms for precisely the
Pharisees uh he kind of saw through
their kind of religious hypocrisy and
such and their um sort of passion for
the fastidious kind of keeping of the
law and like the law will carry the day
and if only we can get all these Sinners
you know to like get their heads on
straight and Obey then the kingdom will
come you know and that was the Pharisees
mentality that doesn't seem to be again
Jesus the friend of tax collectors and
sinners yeah he doesn't really seem to
be uh a Pharisee either uh so what about
the Asen the ases were these sort of
Monkish figures who uh basically they
just headed out to the desert they're
like all you Roman and Judean Sinners
apocalypse will be coming soon and uh
peace out we're out and they kind of
checked out uh again does that sound
like Jesus not so much right he's he's
there in the midst of society not kind
of running away from it uh and then
finally we have uh the zealots the
zealots um were kind of as their their
name indicates they were zealous they
were fiery that's to put it mildly they
were uh basically violent
revolutionaries right they were not
scared to Slit some Roman throats and uh
to usher in the kingdom and also if
their own judian sort of uh countrymen
were say paying the Imperial tax this
will come up kind of later in another
message uh they were willing to kill
their own countrymen who they're like
you're not following the righteous way
you're not willing to usher in the
kingdom of God you're not willing to do
what it takes you know and uh they were
fiercely passionate and committed to the
cause uh they were also probably of all
the groups the the group really most
intensely looking for the Messiah the
deliverer the one who would come and be
that political ruler that that one who
would throw off the Roman oppression and
bring in the kingdom of God and you know
Set uh
kind of the the people and in many ways
the world right so we know actually in
fact that one of Jesus 12 disciples was
a zealot uh we hear there's you know a
list of the 12 in various places so
here's an example from markk
3:18 says Andrew Philip Bartholomew
Matthew Thomas James son of alfus
Thaddius Simon the Zealot so now you
know what a zealot is pretty intense and
although you know we don't have any
evidence necess that like you know all
the disciples were zealots or that that
at least one
um that what I would say though is you
can tell from the disciples questions of
Jesus that they even if they're not like
Allin zealots like you know carrying
around their daggers and ready to murder
people for the cause um you can tell
they kind of have um a little bit of
that Vibe right part of the reason
they're following Jesus is because they
are looking for the Messiah like the
zelw worth and they believe they found
him and they are very pumped about him
right taking on Rome and becoming uh a
leader the leader that they're looking
for so there's there's kind of zealot
impulses um to them right because uh in
the
end what else is a messiah good
for except to precisely put an end to
the Romans and establish yes a religious
um but also a very political kingdom of
God here and now so okay I know that's a
lot of
background um but I I wanted to name
that because I think it'll kind of
inform every message uh to come so all
right so we have a very insightful
conversation along these lines that
occurs between Jesus and Peter in Mark
chapter 8: 27 through
33 it reads Jesus and his disciples went
onto the villages around cesaria
Philippi
on the way he asked them who do people
say I am they replied some say John the
Baptist others say Elijah still others
one of the
prophets but what about you he asked who
do you say I
am Peter answered you are the
Messiah Jesus warned them not to tell
anyone about him he then began to teach
them that the son of man must suffer
many things and be rejected by the the
elders the chief priests and the
teachers of the law and that he must be
killed and after 3 days rise again he
spoke plainly about this and here's the
key line and Peter took him
aside and began to rebuke
him but when Jesus turned and looked at
his disciples he rebuked
Peter get behind me
Satan he said you do not have in mind
the concerns of God
but merely human
concerns what a powerful
moment I mean I'm just I'm just sort of
envisioning this like Peter taking Jesus
aside you know it's it's interesting to
hear someone rebuking Jesus you know
someone setting Jesus straight you know
uh it's always a red flag you know and
I'm just imagine like what was that
conversation you know I'm just kind of I
don't know I'm wondering like is Peter
saying like Jesus you you can't talk
like this it gets the guys down you know
we're you're a winner we're winners
that's not how winners talk you know
positive a positive mental attitude
Jesus this is what you need you and
Jesus I mean his reaction it's so
intense you know I mean it's not like
hey that's off base I disagree I mean
it's it's like that's devil talk you
know like I mean even more than that
it's not even like that's from the devil
it's like you are channeling Satan right
now you know like that's how intense it
is like that's like oh my gosh like
Jesus this is very intense
you but don't you see though that this
is this is this is like this is it this
is precisely a hint of why he is a
strange figure this is precisely a hint
of why no one understood the first thing
about what in the heck Jesus was up
to and it's there's a hint of it right
here I want to um turn back the clock a
bit just before Jesus began his public
Ministry so up to this point you know
he's been like quiet for 30 some odd
years just learning growing practicing
his trade you know basically becoming an
adult and uh he's right though uh he's
led by the spirit into the desert for 40
days and 40 nights right on the cusp of
his first steps into public Ministry and
we pick up this story again in Matthew 8
then Jesus was led by the spirit Into
the Wilderness to be tempted by the
devil after four fasting 40 days and 40
nights he was hungry the tempter came to
him and said if you are the Son of God
tell these stones to become bread Jesus
answered it's written man shall not live
on bread alone but on every word that
comes from the mouth of God the devil
took him to the holy city had him stand
on the highest point of the temple if
you are the Son of God he said throw
yourself down for it's written he will
command his angels concerning you and
they will lift you up in their hands so
that you will not strike your foot
against a stone Jesus answered him it is
also written do not put the Lord your
God to the test again the devil took him
to a very high mountain here's the key
and showed him what all the kingdoms of
the world and their
Splendor all
this I will give you he said said if
you'll Bow Down and Worship
me Jesus said to
him away from me
Satan can you hear the resonance there
away from me Satan get behind me Satan
for it's written Worship the Lord your
God serve him
only in essence it's the same
Temptation you see the church would do
well to remember
that Jesus greatest
Temptation was to grab political
power that's what these two stories I
think are getting at Jesus greatest
Temptation was to grab political power
what do I mean by political power I'm
thinking primarily of all the ways that
we kind of
systematically force people to do
what we want them to
do see here's the thing I don't think it
will uh it'll come as a shock to any of
you that uh human beings are a freaking
hot mess aren't we
we like you just you kind of look at the
world you know and uh it's just like oh
my God I mean know I have to put it on
others you know I just look at myself
and just know like oh my gosh if
everyone's like me like we are sunk you
know this is we got a lot going on in
here and in fact I would say about the
only doctrine of Christianity that
people generally aren't like I don't
believe in that I don't know about that
you know the thing they're like not
skeptical of I would say is the doctrine
of sin that's it's usually fairly
intuitive like yeah there's a lot going
on you know where there's where we're
pretty messed up and because you just
look at the world right and it's crazy
it's like bad people doing bad things
and I mean I have a robust doctrine of
creation so we could say beautiful
amazing people created in the very image
of God which I do believe by the way but
at the same time we all know something
has gotten
Twisted in here something has gone
horribly wrong is going horribly wrong
and there's something um not just
Twisted but but egoic selfish afraid
we're such a reactionary
people and so what is the political situ
what's what's it about what's the game
played there in the social sphere in the
end it's about coercion right force not
necessarily by the way always literally
violence um it could be like the force
of law the force of legislation right
when something comes into law no one's
like and what's your opinion on that you
know do you feel like that should be and
just like it's the law of the land you
know what I mean just the way it's going
to be and and if someone doesn't get in
line with that what's behind that to
ensure that it
happens it's Force it's violence it's
guns and clubs and whatever it takes to
ensure it
happens so like this is just by the way
this is just the way of the world like
this is just kind of how it is and I
would kind of ask like in a world where
things are twisted you know I I'm kind
of sympathetic to I I get like how else
can we operate what do what do we do you
know uh again dusenberry writes Jesus
Temptation reveals a deep and abiding
conflict in his life as it is Remembered
in the gospels and I suggest this
conflict gives rise to three questions
and notice um the verbs in each of these
things will Jesus compel believers
will he punish law
Breakers will he resist
rulers throughout the gospels Jesus
provokes confusion not only among his
critics and judges but among his
disciples this seems to arise from the
fact that he assumes unheard of
authority I think for example the
authority to forgive sins which only God
does and yet he decoupled or he severs
or detaches this Authority from the
power to judge to compel or fight right
this is the very power that makes
political order
possible so the kingdom of God is a
manifestation of power and yet it cannot
be realized by the normal mechanisms of
human power legislation punishment War
let me read that line one more time the
kingdom of God is a man estation of
power and yet it cannot be realized by
the normal mechanisms of human power
legislation punishment War right this I
would argue is why Jesus is a
scandal this is why he is a strange
figure this is why the zealots don't get
him and the judian leaders don't get him
and the Roman leaders don't get him and
his very own
disciples don't get
him Jesus perplexed and mystified them
all and I think he continues to perplex
and mystify us
today both conservative and Progressive
Christians we just don't quite know what
to make of him
still
wrestling with the
implications of who he was and what on
Earth he would have us
do so yes he's a scandal and a strange
figure but maybe just maybe he sees
farther than we
do what do I mean by farther I'm
thinking of Richard Beck in a he wrote a
review of duberry's book and he uh he
points out how Christians today are very
allergic to overs spiritualizing the
kingdom of God right in our minds We are
following a political
Christ and there are some very specific
political implications of following our
political Christ and we see it as
incumbent upon us to here's the critical
step
engage the political Machinery of our
day to
ensure that Justice the kingdom of God
call it whatever you want is
served that it arrives that it's
established but it's that last step I
don't think we quite realize just how
skeptical Jesus was of playing precisely
that game the coercion and force
game in short all the disciples wanted a
political Christ to do just
that but he
refused that's worth
pondering and it's the implications of
why that was and what on Earth it means
for us that will unpack in the coming
weeks
in the name of the Father the Son and
the Holy Spirit
amen so on the
night on the night Jesus was betrayed he
had one final meal with his disciples
and at that meal he held up a loaf of
bread and he broke it and he said Take
and Eat This is my body broken for you
then he held up a cup of wine and he
said this is my blood shed for you
whenever you eat this bread whenever you
drink this cup remember me so as we come
to the table of the Lord tonight as we
take in the body of Christ in the bread
the blood of Christ in the wine we too
participate we too come into deepest
communion and relationship with the one
Jesus called father so the way we'll
participate in communion tonight is
we'll just take this kind of row by row
we'll start here at the front and we'll
just form a line right here in the
middle and work our way um back we
practice what's called an Open Table
meaning if you're here tonight and
something in you you want to participate
even if you maybe don't have like all of
your you know doctrinal eyes dotted or
whatever uh you're welcome to to
participate in this time with us uh you
can partake however you'd like some
folks like to kneel others like to just
take right away or return to their seats
um to partake but no one will lead you
through you know the exact moment of
taking and finally you should know that
the red is wine the white is grape juice
so this is the table not at the church
but of the
Lord and it's made ready for those who
love him and for those who want to love
him more so come you who have much faith
and you who have
little you who have been here often and
you who have not been here long you who
have tried to follow and you who
failed come come because it's the Lord
Jesus himself who invites you and it's
his will that those who want to meet him
should meet him here come to the table
[Music]
that
ch
[Music]
would you guys stand with us as we close
out this last song and let's just make
this our prayer as we go into another
week
[Music]
when my takes me places I don't want to
go Christ
be me and my heart aches with sorrow as
I hit the
RO Christ
be with me
[Music]
when the care of my family takes all
that I have Christ
within when I'm and exhausted as shame
that
I'm Christ
defend
[Music]
me I Rise up today in a strength that is
is not my
[Music]
own I'm held by the pro of God never
alone when I'm tossed to the side and I
want to give up Christ
beide me when I'm breaking my back for
Ever
Enough Christ
beside me when I work but some else get
the
reward
God see me when I ask for
promotion they shut the
door
God he me
[Music]
today in a strength that is not all my
own I'm held by the prise of God I'm
never
alone when I climb the first steps
towards a long H
dree Christ
IAP out in faith and I hope to find
Wings Christ
beath
[Music]
me thank you so much for joining us this
evening and thank you online for joining
us as
well if you are new and we would love
for you to fill out a card at the table
on your way out or just scan the QR code
and fill out the online visitor
card generosity is a key aspect of life
of adoration and worship to give
financially you can scan the QR code or
visit the table T at the table tx.org
we can all use more relational
support and spiritual
connection the way we do that at the
table is through our
meetups if you are not yet part of a
Meetup please scan the QR code to find
one that works for you and my plug this
evening was our Meetup not your mama's
Sunday school class that starts back on
October
27th 24th we're going to be at
centerpiece
so all right I'd like to send you out
now uh this week with a blessing you can
hold your hands out in a posture to
receive or just open your heart to these
words you are a child of
God
you are a
child of God
this is true on your best day and it's
true on your worst day so as you go into
your week ahead with its yet to be
determined highs and lows and everything
in
between go filled with the assurance
that you are
loved you are
worthy you are accepted just the way you
are and go filled with God's Holy Spirit
and the desire to extend these same
Gifts of Grace and unconditional love to
everyone you come in contact with be
blessed have a good week and we hope to
see you back here next Sunday good
[Music]
night I Rise up today in a strength that
is not of my own
[Music]
I'm held by the pro of God I'm never
alone I Rise up today in a strength that
is not my
own I'm held by the promise of God that
I never
[Music]
when I climb the first steps long dream
Christ above me IAP out in faith and I
hope to find Wings Christ
be me